I was on a big DBC political discussion
one night in 2011 talking about this
issue and at that point the mother of
two of my kids got a anonymous phone
call saying tell Hugh Grant to shut the
[ __ ] up really and then they just hang
up and wasn't your apartment broken into
in 1995 and you say on the orders of the
British newspapers that's correct
this is crazy I know crazy and and they
got away with it because the police were
paid off and I know I got to know that
my suspicions were true by this freak
accident when my car broke down in the
middle of the countryside in the middle
of winter and I thought what am I going
to do and this guy pulls up in a car
officer and starts taking pictures of me
and I thought that's weird
why is there a paparazzi in the middle
of Kent anyway to cut a long story short
it turned out he was an ex editor of the
news of the world which is the most
vicious of these papers and he ends up
giving me a lift because I had no other
way of getting to my appointment I know
I time it's good you're being
yeah I know and I said I'd never take a
lift with you and then of course I had I
was so late thank you really but he
starts boasting about everything he's
done hacking phones paying off the
police well this is sinister
relationship between the prime minister
in the head of News News International
which is the Murdoch organisation there
and I thought Christ I wish I had a
recording you know tape recorder to get
all this so what I did was a few months
later I went to I pretended to drop in
on him in his pub down in Kent and just
got him chatting again but I took a
friend and we both had little spy pens
and pens yeah Wow and we pretended to be
making notes on a map and we recorded
the whole thing and then I I published
it in a magazine and the transcript and
that did create a bit of a stir